Ford TV the world is
[Music]
thinking what happened at 911 is we
didn't have a strategy we didn't have
bipartisan agreement we didn't have
American understanding of it and we had
instead a policy
coup in this country a coup a policy
coup some hard-nosed people took over
the direction of American policy and
they never bothered to inform the rest
of us
I went through the Pentagon 10 days
after 9/11 I couldn't stay away from
mother Army I went back there to see Don
Rumsfeld I'd worked for him as a White
House fellow in the 1970s all this in
the book and um and I said am I doing
okay on CNN he said yeah yeah yeah fine
he said uh I'm thinking about he says I
read your book and uh he said uh this is
a book that talks about the kosa
campaign and he said I just want to tell
you he said nobody's going to tell us
where or when we can bomb nobody he said
I'm thinking of calling this a floating
Coalition what do you think about that I
said well sir uh thanks for reading my
book and uh well uh he said thanks
that's all the time I've got really and
um I went downstairs I was leaving the
Pentagon and an officer from The Joint
staff called me into his office and said
I I want you to know he said sir we're
going to attack Iraq and I said why he
said we don't
know he said uh I said well did they tie
Saddam to 911 he said no he said but um
I guess it's they don't know what to do
about terrorism and so uh the they think
but they can attack States and they want
to look strong and so I guess they think
if they take down a state it will
intimidate the terrorists and you know
it's like that old saying he said if the
only two he have is a hammer then every
problem has to be a
nail well I walked out of there pretty
upset and then um we attacked
Afghanistan I was pretty happy about
that we should have and then I came back
to the Pentagon about six weeks later I
saw the same officer I said why uh why
haven't we attacked Iraq we still going
to attack Iraq he said oh sir he says
it's worse than that he said
um he pulled up a piece of paper off his
desk he said I just got this Memo from
the Secretary of defense's office it
says we're going to attack and destroy
the governments in in seven countries in
five years we're going to start with
Iraq and then we're going to move to
Syria Lebanon Libya Somalia Sudan and
Iran I seven seven countries in five
years I said is that a classified memo
he said yes sir I said well don't show
it to me he was about to show it to me
he said because I want to talk about it
and I I I sat on this information for a
long time for about six or eight months
I I was so stunned by this I couldn't
begin to talk about it and I couldn't
believe it would really be true but
that's actually what happened uh these
people took control of the policy in the
United States and I realized then it
came back to me a 1991 meeting I had
with Paul wolfowitz you know in 2001 he
was deputy secretary of defense but in
1991 he was the under secretary of
defense for policy it's the number three
position of the Pentagon and I had gone
to see him when I was a onestar general
I was commanding the National Training
Center I had met him one time he said if
you ever get to Washington come look me
up they always say that well I was there
in Washington it was a Friday afternoon
I'd visited Coen Powell he'd given me 5
minutes of his precious time and sent me
on my way and I was bored in the
Pentagon and and I thought I'll just go
who can I see I I think I'll see wolf
awit so I called and up there he was
available scooter Libby came to the door
I met scooter for the first time and he
brought me in and uh I said to Paul I
said and this is 1991 I said Mr
secretary you must be pretty happy with
the performance of the troops in in
Desert Storm and he said uh well yeah he
said but but not really he said because
the truth is we should have gotten rid
of Saddam Hussein and we didn't and this
was just after the Shia Uprising in the
in March of 91 which we had provoked and
then we kept our troops on the sidelines
and didn't intervene he said but one
thing we did learn he said we learned
that we can use our military in the
region in the Middle East and the
Soviets won't stop us he said' and we've
got about five or 10
years to clean up those old Soviet
client
regimes
Syria Iran Iraq before the next great
superpower comes on to
challenges and it was like you know I'm
coming out of the Mohave Desert I'm been
training troops I haven't been thinking
geost strategy for some time and
suddenly a guy just sort of shoves this
nugget at you well you remember it it
was a pretty stunning thing you mean the
purpose of the militaries to to to start
wars and change governments it's not to
sort of deter conflict we're going to
invade countries and I I you know my
mind was spinning and uh I put that
aside it was like a nugget that you hold
on to this
country was taken over by a group of
people with a policy coup wolfowitz and
Cheney and
Rumsfeld and you could name a half dozen
other collaborat ERS from the project
for a New American Century they wanted
us to destabilize the Middle East turn
it upside
down make it under our control it went
back to those comments in 1991 now did
anybody ever tell you that was there a
national Dialogue on this did senators
and congressmen stand up and denounce
this plan was there a full-fledged
American debate on it absolutely not and
there still isn't
and that's why we're failing in
Iraq because Iran and Syria know about
the
plan all you have to do is read the the
the Weekly Standard and and listen to
Bill Crystal and he blabbermouths it all
over the world Richard Pearl the same
way they could hardly wait to finish
Iraq so they could move into
Syria it was like a lay down oh our
Legions are going to go in there
this wasn't what the American people
voted George Bush into office well they
didn't actually vote him into office but
it wasn't what many of the people
who it wasn't what he campaigned on he
campaigned on a humble foreign policy
the most arrogant foreign policy in
American history he C campaigned on no
peacekeeping no nation building and here
he is with Afghanistan and Iraq it's
astonishing so the root of the problem
is not how many troops are in Iraq
please believe me don't be mad if you're
a Democrat at your Democratic
Congressman because they can't reduce
the troops and frustrate the president
that's not the issue and if you're a
republican don't be mad at the Democrats
because they're fussing with the troops
whether you're a Democrat or Republican
if you're an American you ought to be
concerned about the strategy of the
United States in this region what is our
aim what is our purpose why are we there
why are Americans dying in this
region that is the issue
[Music]
[Laughter]